-I'm talking to the one and only
Jason Bateman right now.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's exactly right.
I want to talk "Ozark."
"Ozark" is a very spoilery show,
and so I don't want to spoil
anything for anyone
who hasn't seen it.
-We all die at the end.
Is that a spoiler?
-You can't even -- you can't
even joke and say that.
-But it's good to -- Yeah.
-You can't even joke.
-It's an old coyote --
You know, the dynamite thing?
-No, that's not exactly
what happened. [ Laughs ]
-It's fine.
-That would be unbelievable.
Who -- Do people try
to get spoilers out of you?
Because I wouldn't.
I would not try to do that.
-No. My wife kind of.
And then I'll start to --
-She must know.
-She doesn't really know
much of anything.
I -- I made such a mistake,
Jimmy.
No, no.
-Oh, my God.
You're going to be
in big trouble.
-Oh, she knows I'm joking.
-She's the greatest.
-She does try to --
-Oh, because you know why?
Because then
she'll be in trouble,
because if she'll go to a dinner
or something,
then she has to lie and go,
"I can't tell you."
-Right, right.
-So don't put her
in that position.
-Exactly.
-That kind of -- Does that help?
-I -- No one really tries
to get the spoilers out,
but I do like to just go ahead
and offer them,
like I just did here.
I mean, but the death
the four of us get --
-No, no, no, no, no.
You can't.
But have you accidentally
spoiled anything for anyone?
-Yeah, I was actually --
I was actually watching
a cut of one of these scenes
that we was working
with the editor,
and I was watching it
on my computer,
and Amanda, my wife,
walked in.
And she walked in,
she was talking to me.
"Hey, so. blah, blah, blah --"
And she looks and she watched
one of the characters die,
and she was like
"God, d--"
[ Laughter ]
-Like, "Why did I walk in now?
And now it's ruined."
-Yeah.
-Cause that's one of the --
the twists that come in,
I remember --
Questlove, you saw "Ozark" in,
like, a day or so?
-Yes.
-And so --
-Come on.
Quest was like, "Dude,
where are you at?"
I'm like, "It's so interesting
and so fun."
And he's like,
"No, no, no.
Have you got to anything crazy?"
I go, "Nothing crazy yet."
-Didn't "SNL" do
a sketch on that,
where like with streaming shows,
you can't talk about any show.
"Are you watching it?"
"Don't talk about that."
And then they talk about it,
and don't talk about that.
-No, you're not allowed
to talk about anything.
-One of the bummers
about streaming,
but I like having the choice
of being able
to watch them all at once.
-How long has it been and when
did you start doing "Ozark?"
Five -- And so, this is
the fourth -- five years.
-Five years.
-Yeah, but maybe six with COVID.
-Yeah.
-I don't know.
-So six years. I think you
should catch up and understand.
I think it's totally
understandable
if someone does spoil it.
I won't do it,
but I will tell you that
it's one of the greatest shows.
Every performance is knockout.
Laura Linney is a knockout.
A knockout.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Julia, a knockout.
You are -- dude,
you're unbelievable.
I can't imagine any other
human being doing you.
I tried to do
an impression of you,
and now -- I know.
-Didn't you do one
last time I was here?
-I did, and now people ask me
to do it.
They go, "Can you --"
-Wait, I kind of forget.
It's hurtful, I think,
probably, right?
[ Laughter ]
-Most impressions are,
but no, it's out of love.
-All you needed to do
is put on slippers,
PJs, and watch a Dodger game
and fall asleep. That's perfect.
-I was just more like,
[imitating Jason] "G-Gang? Gang?
Gang? Guys? Guys?"
-[ Laughs ]
-"Guys?"
[Normally] That's all
I really did.
That's all.
-That's pretty good.
-[Imitating Jason]"G-Guy--
G-Guy-- Guys? OK, guys? OK?"
[Normally]
But I can't -- you know.
I got to -- I got to say,
I also did some deep diving,
and I might be wrong
in saying this,
but do you come up
with the drawings?
The like -- kind of
the graphics?
-The little symbols
at the beginning?
-Yes.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Is that you?
-Yeah, yeah.
I work with this great graphic
artist, Neil Kellerhouse,
who's worked
a lot with David Fincher,
and I'm a huge Fincher fan.
And so I had reached out to him
and I said, "So here's the deal.
We got to do Netflix --
we got to do an open --
I didn't want to do,
like, a credits sequence.
Like, don't you hate
you got to watch a minute
and a half of credits for a show
you watch all the time.
It's like, let's get
to the story.
So I wanted to do something
that was just, like,
5 minutes -- 5 seconds long.
But Netflix was like, "We got to
see the name of the show."
Like, people have already
clicked.
They know what show
they're watching.
-[ Laughs ] Yeah, like, "What?
Is this 'Bozark?'
We never heard of that."
You go, "No, no."
We know what we're watching.
-So I said, "All right,
all right, all right.
So we're going to put the name
of the show in this --
in this little 5-second thing,
but we're going to not do it
with O-Z-A-R-K,
we'll do symbols
that are in the shape of Z-R --
Z-A-R-K.
Which I don't know
if a lot of people know that --
-I didn't know that.
-The symbols are in the shape.
So it's -- you got the "O,"
and then the first symbol
is, if you look closely,
it's a "Z" then an "A,"
then an "R."
-Are you serious?
-But those symbols
are also harbingers of things
that are coming
in the episode.
-Right.
That's why Neil
is such a genius.
He can work all this stuff out.
-I watch -- I go through
every episode
and I give him, like, 10 or 12
things that are important
in the episode,
and then he decides
which one of those things
lend themselves to a symbol.
Like I'll say,
a fish plays a big part.
And so he'll go,
"Oh, yeah, okay.
So a fish can bend into an 'R'
or a 'K,' or..."
So he works on it,
then he sends them to me.
I go, "Yeah, I make --
that's too obvious.
Make that a little less so --
it looks too much like a 'K.'"
So that's a fun thing we do
together.
It's brilliant
because you're like,
"Wait --" You try to almost
guess what the episode
would be about. Why?
I'm not even -- I'm never close.
-The only rule is that it can't
be something that existed
before you go to that card.
In other words,
that little cold opening,
it can't be
anything from there.
-No.
-So it's from that point
forward.
-And so you're doing this,
the series finale.
You do -- I don't know what it
is, but your last scene
with Laura Linney.
I don't know what it is,
but when you do that,
there are tears.
-There some --
the actual -- the last scene
we shot of everything was a --
was a big moment in the show.
It's not the last scene
in the show,
but it's the last scene
that we shot.
So, yeah, there was
some melancholy.
It was kind of -- but you know,
it's bittersweet
because we were all really happy
that we kind of made it
to the finish line
without screwing things up
too bad, I hope.
-You made -- No.
You made great TV.
-Thank you.
-I mean,
that's even bigger than TV.
I don't know what --
it's like the movies.
Like mini movies.
They're unbelievable.
-A bunch of incredible people
in that crew
and the incredible writing,
and it was -- we were
very, very lucky.
-Is there any world where
there's a happy ending
to the show?
-It is. Well, that's what
Chris Mundy,
who is our incredible writer and
his staff and our showrunner,
he wants -- you know,
because he and I, we talk
before the beginning
of every season
about what are we going
to try to get done,
and then I don't mess around
with the writing.
I'm not smart enough.
But we talk about the themes.
And with the final season,
the whole thing was like,
"Well, how are we
going to end it?"
Should the Byrde family
pay a bill?
You know? Like, should
they get away with it?
Should they not?"
And so he said,
"Well, I want it to be
a happy ending,
but there's got to be
a little bit of a,
'Well, is it happy for them?'"
And so hopefully,
the audience will think,
"Ah, they've kind of threaded
the needle
between a happy ending,
but that there's a little bit
of -- they're limping.
-Yeah.
-Did you --
Do you know going into it
where it was going to end up?
Like, from the first season?
You're like, "Let's do this.
Let's hope that it's a hit."
-We didn't have the finish line
done at the very,
very beginning,
but we were pretty clear
that it should be
a family show --
not a family show --
Not an AA -0-
[ Laughter ]
-It is so not a family show.
It is far from it.
[ Laughter ]
-A show about a family.
-Yeah, it's a morning show.
You really got to watch it
with the kids.
You got to get the kids over.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They love it. Oh, my God.
-Yeah. A lead-in to "Alf."
-[ Laughs ]
Oh, my gosh.
Congrats, buddy,
on everything.
You know I love you.
I want to show a clip.
Here's Jason Bateman
and Laura Linney in "Ozark".
Take a look at this.
-You suggested this life.
-Long time ago.
-You knew better
than me what this was.
They cut out a man's eyes
in front of you.
-Hey. I got us into this.
You're getting us out of this.
Yeah, we --
We chose this together.
Nobody talked you into this.
You were excited about this.
-You were a good salesman.
-Oh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Come on.
Jason Bateman.
"Ozark" returns
for its final episodes
April 29 on Netflix.
Steven, hello.
More "Tonight Show"
after the break.